مشكله تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط
هجوم بطائرات مسيره على مقاطعه موسكو جاء
ذلك بينما تشهد جبهات شمال شرقي اوكرانيا
تصعيدا كبيرا خصوصا في مقاطعه
التطورات على الجبهات الاخرى يتابعها من
اوديسا مع مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي وبين
موسكو مع مراسل الجزيره امين درغام ابدا
معك عامر لافي عن اخر لا تتطورات خاصه ما
يجري من عمليه مكثفه في كوبيانسك
نعم عبد القادر ودعني ابدا بدايه بالخبر
الذي شغل حي الزنكبيرا في وسائل الاعلام
وفي اهتمام الساسه الاوكرانيين الان وهو
الحدث الابرز حاليا الا وهو استهداف مدينه
مدينه شرنيف هذه المدينه التي استهدفت
بصاروخ في الساحه الرئيسيه لهذه المدينه
وهو ما اسفر وفقا للداخليه الاوكرانيه عن
مقتل سبعه من الاشخاص وحوالي 110 من
الجرحى في هذا المكان كما ذكرنا هو الساحه
الرئيسيه في هذه المدينه في يوم السبت
وهذا السبت ليس فقط عطله نهايه اسبوع
وانما ايضا عيد ديني حيث كان هناك اعداد
من الناس تخرج من الكنيسه ايضا يوجد خلف
الكنيسه وخلفه المسرح الوطني في هذه
الساحه حديقه يرتادها الناس في هذا اليوم
هناك ايضا كان موقف لحافلات النقل العام
كان هناك العديد من الناس واكثر من سقطوا
جرحى كانوا في هذه في هذا الموقف موقف
حافلات الرئيسكي تحدث عن الموضوع وقال بان
روسيا حولت يوم السبت عادي الى يوم حزن
وخساره والم وقال بانه على الجميع ان يعزز
التعاون المشترك بين الجميع من اجل ما
وصفه بمحاربه الارهاب الروسي اذا هذا هو
ابرز ربما الامور الان لكن قبلها كانت
اوكرانيا قد تعرضت لهجوم واسع ايضا
بالمسيرات طوال الليل وحتى الصباح وفقا
لقياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه فان سبعه
عشره مسيره استهدفت مقاطعات في الشمال
والوسط والغرب وقالت قياده القوات المسلحه
انها تمكنت من اسقاط خمسه عشره من هذه
المسيرات من نوع شاهد ايرانيه الصنع وقالت
قياده عمليات الجنوب ان الروس حاولوا عمل
نوع من المناوره لالهاء الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه عندما حركت سفينه تحمل ثمان
ثمانيه صواريخ من نوع كروز في البحر
الاسود على اعتبار ان يظن الجميع ان
الهجوم سيكون من جهه البحر من الجنوب لكن
دخلت هذه المسيرات من الشمال وتحديدا من
شمال خركيف وبالحديث عن اخر كيف طبعا تبقى
ان على طول خطوط المواجهه من الشمال الى
الجنوب في الشرق مدينه كوبيانس التابعه
لخار كيف هي اعنف جبهات المواجهه الان
هناك على ما يبدو ان صح وصفها استمات
روسيه في محاوله للسيطره على هذه المدينه
التي كانت قد خرجت منها القوات الروسيه
قبل عام عندما انسحبت من شرق خار كيف من
حوالي 3000 كيلو متر مربع من هذه المناطق
الان هناك قصف شديد على هذه المدينه ايضا
قياده عمليات المنطقه الشرقيه تتحدث عن ان
التكتيك الذي كان متبع في مخمود تحاول
روسيا استعمال تكتيك مشاهد له ايضا في
كوبيس الا وهو استخدام شركات قتال خاصه
مشابهه لفاينر تحدث عن شركه تسمى ستورش
زيد وقالت بان هذه الشركه ايضا من المرتز
كما تقول لكنها اقل كفاءه من فاقنار
وبالتالي هي التي تحارب وتقاتل اضافه الى
العديد من طبعا التعزيزات التي ارسلت الى
كومبياس كوبيانس والقصف المستمر هناك
اليوم المتحدث باسم قياده العمليات في
المنطقه الشرقيه
قال بان قصف كفيف استهدف هذه المنطقه لكنه
عاد واكد بان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
قادره على صدد هذه الهجمات وايقاع خسائر
كبيره في صفوف القوات الروسيه المهاجمه
فنستمع لمقال
يركز العدو هجماته في اتجاه كوبيانس وينفذ
قصفا مدفعيا كثيفا وغارات جويه قصفت
مواقعنا اكثر من 600 مره يوم امس بمختلف
انواع المدفعيه والدبابات ومدافع الهون
ونفذ ثلاث محاولات هجوميه في منطقه
سينكوفكا وايفانوفكا وفي كوبيانس وقتل 36
جنديا روسيا واصيب سبعه وخمسون كما اسرنا
خمسه منهم ودمرنا دبابتين وناقلتي جنود
اضافه لاليات عسكريه عده
ايضا في داخل الروسي تشكل المسيرات
الاوكرانيه التطور الابرز امين
نعم نعم صحيح عبد القادر اليوم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اصدرت اربعه بيانات على
غير العاده هذه البيانات منذ فجر اليوم
تتحدث عن هجمات متفرقه جنوبا من شبه جزيره
القرم مرورا
بمقاطعه موسكو وايضا
بمنطقه الى الشمال من موسكو وكل هذه
الهجمات التي تحدثت عنها الوزاره او
تقريبا معظمها تم باستخدام مسيرات في
مقاطعه موسكو تحدثت الوزاره عن اسقاط
مسيره قربه مدينه كرسنا غورس كالمتاخمه
لموسكو من الجهه الشماليه الغربيه دون ان
يوقع هذا الهجوم اي ضحايا او خسائر ماديه
وفي الشمال وتحديدا في مقاطعه
اكدت الوزاره على ان طائره عسكريه تضررت
وشب حريق
مطار خلال اسقاط مسيره كانت قد
تحاول ان تستهدف المبنى الرئيسي لمطار
عسكري في تلك المنطقه التي تبعد باكثر من
600 كيلومتر عن الحدود الاوكرانيه وباربعه
400 كيلو متر تقريبا الى الشمال من
العاصمه الروسيه فجرا ايضا وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كانت قد اكدت ان الدفاعات الجويه
اعترضت صاروخا من طراز اس 200 كان يستهدف
على ما يبدو جسر القرم وقالت بانها احبطت
ذلك الهجوم على وتا على البيان اليومي
الذي تصدره الوزاره منذ بدء ما تطلق عليه
روسيا بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا والذي اكدت من خلاله عن عدد كبير
من الاستهدافات في كل من دونيسك ايضا في
مقاطعه خرسون والوزاره كدت انها استهدفت
هتضيفها اليسرى من نهر دنيبر مجموعه من
القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا استهدافات اخرى في
كل من خميليتسكي في المنطقه الغربيه من
اوكرانيا وطبعا عدد من النقاط العسكريه في
مناطق متفرقه طبعا بعد كل تصعيد يتم من
خلاله استهداف العمق الروسي خاصه باستخدام
المسيرات من قبل الجانب الاوكراني نلحظ
تصعيدا من قبل روسيا ايضا باستهداف العمق
الاوكراني باستهداف منشات عسكريه البنيه
التحتيه خطوط خطوط الامداد وايضا طرق نقل
المعدات العسكريه والذخائر والاسلحه
وطبعا هذه الايام كانت استثنائيه باعتبار
ان موسكو تتعرض للمره الثامنه منذ مايو
الماضي لهجمات بمسيرات كان اخر هذه
الهجمات حينما تم اسقاط مسيره امس في
منطقه
العاصمه الروسيه التي ايضا اكدت السلطات
الروسيه على ان تلك العمليه هي عمليه الصد
لم تسفر عن خسائر بشريه في مقاطعه ايضا
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا عبد القادر اليوم
محافظ هذه المقاطعه
اكد على ان المقاطعة تعرضت لمحاولات هجوم
مؤكده على ان الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لاهداف
جويه لم يسميها فوق سماء تلك المقاطعه
التي والى جانب بريانسكو وايضا روستوف
وغيرها من المقاطعه الحدوديه تتعرض ايضا
لمحاولات هجوم متكرره بحسب ما تعلن عنه
بشكل مستمر طبعا السلطات الروسيه امين من
موسكو وعامر لفي شكرا جزيلا لكما